everybody was going on play here and we
are live in Italy we are in Florence
Ponte Vecchio which is a famous bridge
from the 13th century right there and we
were filming our conan italy show so
this is our second day in Florence
we are leaving Florence today before we
leave it's a gorgeous day so we thought
we'd get outside and I'm doing a lot of
video Jeff for us the worst surprise our
wedding the worst he hates he hates it
when I do this
hates I'm gonna do this okay guys so
we're headed back we got also halfway
beautiful view this way
going this way as a sting game zero
you're like okay guys guys we're going
back in it that way you're gonna they're
gonna talk about the construction area
guys all right
no say I had a Facebook we rely on
Facebook I gotta go back we get it back
all right right now we got to get we got
to get back for do a long shot of Conan
and Jordan from way down the street so
we can get the beauty of the street the
architecture here again we're live in
Italy in Florence and we're shooting our
Coney Italy show and there's Conan and
Jordan right back there it's fantastic
traveling is dirt and working as it be
paid an hourly rate Wow toys truck these
are four things
construction
now Jason there's a taste to it only in
Florence Oh enforcement and other public
had that happen is amazing you feel
acids of a construction site
I didn't say I start I just said has a
quality hood sounded orange miss but
also a constructionist an inherent
building this that makes
friends
pleasure pain is this everything ma'am
yes
my pleasure would you trust me
a trapeze
leaving here bleeding this construction
site
I don't think I've ever
help me see things more it's macaroni
with
put a down jacket on the dachshund
that's why I like down
[Music]
adjacent is still gorgeous newer
I mean why would simply modern concepts
you after the moment why would you try
what you want a photo with anybody else
in it he would loan or creep
you only take photos by yourself I want
to capture the experience of your
courses no I'm not you have to take if
you want to have to be in a picture it
should be a jordan picture which means
you're in it alone but that does not
accurately represent this experience
okay I want to celebrate my
okay here we go this is important
you know what's in front of you talking
use the word various lie
talk about it
the many types of experiences right
someone who uses the work various and it
talks about diffuse experience you only
have one expression master I don't see
you you always look exactly the same in
your photographs you look exactly like
this guy you know like you're chasing
after Keanu Reeves in the matrix say mr.
answers doing and disappointing sits
just say in the perceptive person will
tell some
it's just such an average degree amazing
could stare at that all day
what is it what are you talking about we
get clouds in Los Angeles I mean there's
textures to the Clarins there's clouds
everywhere look at the level within the
a pilot you talking about
it's such [ __ ] everything you're
saying means nothing look at the texture
of the clouds you don't get that much
Angeles yes you do there are clouds
everywhere they're not different clouds
here in Florence I got news for you
buddy boy there's a bunch of clouds and
they blow around these are the same
clouds that are gonna be in Los Angeles
at some time okay so enough for the-- Oh
everything is different here oh look
Ruffini was a graffiti here influence no
that's not true it's the same same yes
do I love Florence real Italy I'm sure
but they're in the same class same class
when I travel I bet you doofuses and she
remember what they felt like let your
rub on that stone close and highs yeah
and notice the coldness of the stone and
the texture
this guy's perving out on a wall
everybody running his hands buried see
oh you've rubbed up against the Coliseum
I bet you haven't that you've left a
little DNA at every crime scene it's
ridiculous you're not getting anything
by touching that stone you're a big fake
there's nothing no okay I'll do it too
oh yes there's a stone
a rockiness italy everyone is an
American student there everyone you're
from where Roma this is my friend Jordan
and he loves the Italian people and he
says he can communicate with you and get
your essence as creepy as it sounds
go ahead step in here Jordan speak to
this man Gigi say do you like beef steak
you just asked him do you like deep
space
transfer question please use be called
English a little bit a little bit of
English do you think does he sound
Italian to you or you can you tell he's
American
you can tell us it's not that great
right
did you know so he's absent accent is a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] yes oh shoot
accent yes a little bit no no it's okay
you said it
no no but go back we have you [ __ ] now
my question is he's from Long Island
he's from Long Island he's not Italian
he's trying to convince people here he's
Italian is he Italian does he look at
him super he seems Italian no he's just
wearing sunglasses that's all don't be
take off the sunglasses look is he
Italian now no now he's not now you see
the dead eyes of a guy from Long Island
now he's Italian again he says the
clouds here in Italy are different from
the clouds anywhere else do you think
that's true be the clouds or clouds what
are you talking about you think the air
here is different when you smell the air
the air is all Oh so the air is
different you were born in a white
castle ridiculous I'll show you where
he's from this he says he's Italian this
this he's from this place right here
that's where he's from us he had a
Facebook own Oh Facebook I'm sorry to
turn my back on that road bleh never
tells me when I'm on Facebook and when
I'm not there's a really good chance
that someday I'll be committing a murder
bleh will be shooting me on Facebook
live and so and then I'll be caught
because this jerk didn't tell me how are
you enjoying yourself so far Jordan this
is a fantastic day
- beautiful sunshine crisp air yeah
we're about to leave Florence but I wish
we could stay for at least a few more
days
yes we're moving on we're headed we're
gonna stand so for a second cuz I think
we're bumping into people we loving
Florence absolutely gorgeous then we're
moving on we're gonna go into Tuscany I
believe what are your interests no I
know we're in Tuscany by the way if
you're watching this right now this
would be a good time to go and make a
sandwich cause he's gonna talk about 40
minutes so go ahead keep going Florence
is a city of meat going to the city of
Arts Florence is the city of romance and
a city of romance where where else are
we going in Italy I don't know how much
of that we're leading to chance but I
know that we're going to Naples we're
gonna be roadtrip is my favorite way to
travel because you're really yeah you
know the way sometimes two really good
friends go on a trip together to Europe
imagine that but the people aren't
friends in fact one of them kind of
hates the other whereas that's what it's
like where do we eat last night we ate
it one of your favorite restaurants
during doing SP pas la it was actually
outside of the city a place that not
many tourists get but of course we have
the legendary Florentine dish
mistake alakina yeah steak we had steak
and it was a steady state a very
specific type of cattle very specific
method of cooking yes it was dead and
they put it enough there you go special
delicious I do say it was delicious mr.
Lincoln when you would actually shoot
for the show Facebook what stay posted
kids out there you money you hear knit
caps and your rap music I know what you
guys are up to this thing I don't make
any sense
hello I see you gonna be face you're on
Facebook right now I'll be over here
I'll take dog team your phone okay
glides by nine people worldwide no it's
incredible but this guy he's 24 years
old yeah this is what red wine do do
amazing everything about you your shoes
your help me with my style I want to be
you you I want to wear your glasses and
ride your bicycles but I right now can I
wear your glasses may I ride your
bicycle okay I want to be you see Jordan
then I might ask advice cool is this guy
now I wanna I want to be as cool as him
you mind if I Drive it here we go
fantástico what do you think
did I look did you think that I had a
good style just then George I felt
nothing I felt nothing for years really
anywho hey how are you we're here in
Florence absolutely gorgeous here
people are amazing running into a lot of
Americans just find that woman last
night a young woman let me get on the
phone and do a live chat with her mom it
was no hi that's her and she was like in
a cab but I was telling her mom that her
daughter's fine she's with her friends
she's safe it was just a pretty funny
experience yeah that was good a lot of
South Koreans to South Koreans who are
that's funny too because because I went
to Korea I have all these fans in South
Korea and they're always really excited
to see me and then they can't believe
that they're in Italy and I'm here my
travel shows you're starting to collide
yeah that's not the kind of neat thing
is that I go to a country and people
from the countries that I've been to
before know me from there and then they
see me here and it all starts to get
variants you're slowly taking over the
world very go by so very very very very
very slow that's great but we've been
having a great time the Sun is out today
it's actually a lot of people say well
why would you everyone only seems to
come to Italy it's really nice right now
yeah it's not too crowded it's gorgeous
absolutely I'm just doing a little plug
here for the Italian tourists poor they
don't just only come to get lead in the
summer you know that's right and we're
leaving we're hitting the road we're
hitting the road and where we going next
I don't know I think we're we might be I
think we're headed dry more countryside
Luca yes I think we're head towards the
luca of lucca i bench you before years
ago I was in Lucca Oh City it's kind of
cool there
have you been to Florence before yes oh
wow
and gotta go Florence Florence
absolutely and have you been eating
how's the food bit it's insane it's just
insanity you know you try to be moderate
you can't keep bringing more do you
normally you eat pretty healthy normally
I try to but here you know I don't think
this is unhealthy food no oh no I think
like the de Florentine steak is really
amazing yeah I would say literally they
cook it it's so rare last night I did
CPR in my steak I brought it I can't try
to hit it with a fork and it would have
not forced on me there we go I think
we're actually is there a vein right
there over here all right cool do you
want to say goodbye to face pain my
facebook thanks for checking out
whatever we're doing and hope it makes
some sense
that's right it'll be a good show
absolutely when it's all put together
whenever that is whenever that is
you